the day was august 31st 1997 and if you
were alive you likely remember where you
were when you heard the news of princess
diana's death in a paris car crash here
to talk to us about her lasting impact
is royal expert john quelch welcome john
tomorrow marks 25 years of the people's
princess passing why does her passing
still have such an impact today
thank you very much and greetings to all
in las vegas natalia um so i remember i
was in denver in a hotel
and just as
americans remember where they were on 9
11 and older americans remember where
they were when jfk passed away uh for
most british people uh this was an
equally memorable moment and i think
really the the
dignity and beauty of diana is really
captured in
your term the people's princess because
the monarchy was really at that time
regarded as
very inaccessible aloof and distant and
she of course brought
a common humanity to the monarchy which
on the one hand increased the appeal to
the pope to the public but at the same
time it was very difficult for the
british monarchy with its tradition
of
being above and separate from the people
to
cater to that particular personality and
to embrace it in their midst
so
i think most americans would remember
the seminal seminal moment when she was
at a harlem hospital
and hugged
a seven-year-old boy who had aids at a
time when it was very
difficult for people to
accept that disease and so she brought a
tremendous level of humanity
to
the appreciation of those who had and
were suffering from aids and it was that
appreciation of the underdog that human
touch that i think
more than her
obvious physical
appearance and her attractiveness and
appeal in that regard that's what really
i think made her stand out for british
people
she also really stood out for americans
here why do you think her death had such
an impact on people in the united states
i think that
there was a
a fairy tale element to the entire
romance
although she was
not
a commoner as we would say in britain
she was a member of an aristocratic
family
nevertheless she was
i think someone who came from
a relatively normal life and was thrust
into
the
challenge of managing buckingham palace
and all the personalities that involved
and those of you who have watched the
crown in detail will appreciate those
challenges and again i think for
americans
you know it's very uh
very heartening to see someone still re
retaining their authenticity when
they're challenged in the context that
they're living to
adapt to become someone else absolutely
john thank you so much for your insight
and i think a lot of our minds will be
on her and her family tomorrow we
appreciate you taking the time with us
my pleasure natalia